okay now before I start my
presentation I just want to go as most
disclaimer all the proposed
our own stage 1 in tc39 process which
means that the community decided that
the use case of this proposed that this
proposed tries to solve are valid and it
worth more investigation investigation
nothing else okay
the main purpose here is you still have
a nice nick peak about of the future
javascript and understand the use case
broad pros and cons of this or each one
of these features and create some words
about the amazing and work that this
attorney committee is doing in order to
make our language better so if you have
more a thing if I have any any concerns
or if wanna show your excitement about
some of the features or even though
feature that I'm not mentioning here go
to this link is their github repository
all the proposed there they work on is
there so the agenda for today is I will
talk about pattern matching pipeline
operator binaries T ast and a dangerous
thing I will throw some opinions on that
so if you will if you see this red
border it means it's my opinion so if
you disagree like let's talk to me
afterwards and otherwise just ignore it
because it's just my opinion with that
sound
[Music]
okay to give a your background
motivation about the first proposal I
want to first talk about conditionals in
JavaScript in JavaScript nowadays we
have three ways to do conditionals if
you're if knows the statement switch
statement in ternary eternal expression
to help you to get the picture an
expression is something that they value
a it's dot Val value and a statement is
just something that does something I
will show quickly how each one of these
words so an if-else statement requires a
condition which is thrown by this
parenthesis and which can evaluate to
true fee or false value if the condition
is true it is equids the first block
which is the curly brackets there and if
not if it's false goes to the to the
else block if there is one okay just to
help you to get Peter I I create this
snippet which is just a function that
outputs a moyes that mostly reflects the
the the the the temperature this is so I
forgot to firstly it is to Freud sorry
okay so as you can see here like you
have a an ephah statement and then if
this is true it returns like all the
fire otherwise it falls to the LC
statement which is another heavy
statement so with this you can Cheney if
an Elsa statement and this can go wild
like I'm not even talk about that nasty
if so if if I have like oh and this kind
of sequential checks with just a small
code to react to this I think switch
statement could fit
better so let's check how a switch
statement works so as I told you that if
statements very handy when you want to
just react to a cup of choice and you
know or we have a big chunk of code to
run but when I will have like a
multiple-choice with just a small code
to react to this I think maybe a switch
statement could be a good choice
so how switch statement works so have
like under between disbalances an
expression and it evaluates this
expression try to match with one of
these cases statements and owns the
expression matched to the expression
inside the case statement this is the
entry point of the the switch statement
so the the the this is a key to enter in
this point it get it gets going until
the end so that's why we have this break
statement to jump out of the the switch
statement so going back to our initial
example this is the way I just make the
we will wrote the the previous example
using switch statement as you can see
here you oftentimes we just use the
constant in the case statement but here
see someone to trust us the truth value
so I put that constant in the the switch
expression and the comparison inside the
case expression the third one like is
the ternary expression so the ternary
operator became popular recently most by
the fictional programmers and who tries
to write the code which am as much
expression as possible it's it basically
works as the following give it a
condition if it's true it executes that
block after the question mark it's false
or if it's false
after there the column so sister Mary is
an expression you can use error function
and to make the that previous example
more concise and but it is readable I
don't know I'm not heated dirt
there are people that really like this
approach as you can see there are a lot
of ways to do conditional in JavaScript
today
what's the matter of the fourth one
could you imagine what could happen if
you mix if statement with switch
statement plus the power for the power
of distracting parameter very matching
so transcend it better how I create this
for example which I have we have like a
list of shapes with size color type and
I want I want to log all these circles
red squares and big ball triangles just
to context wise this will be our sample
entry and this is how this is one of
partition solution for the problem but
it's tricky that it becomes tricky
because it can easily become hard to
reason about because the more checks we
have then the bigger is the if statement
and this is the way we can achieve this
with with pattern matching so because of
the time I want to explain the concepts
of the pattern matching if you are
interested in interest in this we can
talk more about this later so this is
the first first part part of it which is
the case statement it defines the start
of the pattern matching statement so it
receives just one value as input which
is inside this parenthesis which is the
case expression so then we have
afterwards the wain clause so the
windows is divided in two parts the
match pattern which is this first pair
of curly brackets and the Wayne Clause
body
so whenever the shape of the parent the
the pattern and makes the shape of the
expression it gets into this it executes
the this body
so as you can see to achieve the second
condition I just need to create another
query let's say not another pattern and
so in here you have something different
you can check that we have like we are
matching the size and then afterwards we
have this if statement which not a an if
statement it's just it's called magic
word so whenever the first part match
even though the like if the the match
guard returns false we don't execute
that that body we just skip the last
part is when I will put a variable and
stay alone on this match better it's
just it just matched everything so it's
kind of the default statement for force
which case okay now even though man
parent may is powerful we should not
forget to use the right tool to do the
right job remember or whether example
using part and a pattern matching we
could do like this so keep in mind that
not everything they need to use a hammer
okay dangerous part this brings me some
some wishes like since we have three
ways to do conditionals in JavaScript
and to our arrays a statement so I would
like to see parent matching linking
JavaScript as as expression so we could
have because now as its proposed its
proposed as a statement and I think and
having this I know there are there are a
lot of chronic case that needs to be
covered to make this as as an expression
but I would like to wait more to have
this and have this as expression but if
this lens as a as a statement and if we
have a do expression aligned in
JavaScript we can write prior image we
do expression so let's go to the next
one
before introduce the next proposal let's
check
what is functional composition in how we
can do this even in JavaScript so
function composition is a mathematical
mathematical concept that allows you to
combine two or more functions to create
a new function okay so to help you to
get the picture
let's could cook a bento I came up with
this example just because it's I think
it's easier to reason about food and
because I like to use a mooch so when I
was like whenever have a function that
you the output of the previous function
use as input to the next function you
like you think that you need to compose
those but like to do this nowadays one
of the possible ways is to do this
within this intermediary variables but
it becomes verbose just just because you
need to create this variable just to
hold this function to this value until
use this as input to the next function
so I don't want I don't want to use this
intermediate variables okay like how can
we do this better right I can do like
this but it's a trick treasonable
because the way the data flow is
different that the way we read the code
because the the data flows from the
inner function to the our reference
outer function but the way we read this
like top down left right and there is a
1x or problem that the more we change
these functions the more an asset that
we have this call so it's not so
readable okay we can use low - flow for
of for pipe in this function and a more
readable way let's say or ramp down a
pipe or even vanilla J's right so
wouldn't be nice to have this capability
somehow incorporate into JavaScript
without having to rely to external
library or some homemade functions so
let's bring the the second proposal of
this talk
pipeline operator so pipeline operator
is a syntactic sugar for this use case
it creates a streamline
chain of functions you know readable in
functional manner and in its backhoe
backwards compatible so that initial
example of great Beto could be used to I
only have five minutes sir really I just
started oh I need to hurry up okay so
use the pipeline operator I can do like
this so it becomes clear that the way
there are flow is the way I read the
code and this will be the sugar to this
one it's nice right
so what if my chain function like
receives more one more parameter let's
suppose that we have this add fish to
create an agree and we need to define
which kind of fish we need to add to the
to the rice once we have it so we could
wrap this function with an arrow
function so but in a minimum proposal
you need to wrap the arrow function with
parentheses otherwise you'll have a
syntax error and okay I just figure out
that I don't know how to a simpler bento
so I need to delegate this task to an
iron I a sync third-party function how
to treat this async function using
pipeline operator so I could await this
function but the problem is this line by
line aphorism Vigo's because I don't
know for example if my implementation of
the add to bento is just a
straightforward async implementation I
want to have this function to be the
sugar to this line six but if for some
reason I have uncommon implementation
which I return another function that I
want to call with the the the rice to
create an agree or to create the the
bento I want to I want this line to be
the alone among this function to be the
sugar to the line 6 the
problem is that the MIMO proposal there
is no guarantee that I I can that our
wait step could be the sugar to the one
on an order yes as you can see the the
minimal poser has two caveats that needs
to be others in order to have in order
to proceed in and the sitter nine
proposal there are two comparing
proposals to that try to address these
two issues in different ways I will
first explain the smart pipeline
proposal so this mark pipeline proposal
creates our token so this token is like
the placeholder for the results of the
previous step so whenever whenever we
want to you have like a to a weight a
function or you have to pass one extra
premier like as as I showed you you can
you can use the top style or whenever
you have like this is straight for a
call you just use the very bear style so
just couple of rules for SmartPak nine
when I will have parentheses are called
by square brackets you need to use topic
style otherwise issue do you can use
various time which brings to a small
corner case which is how to handle
co-occurring so when you have current
you have to use you have - I have more
50 more minutes
okay okay
backtrack okay when you have curry since
you have the the parentheses if you
don't if though if you try to use the
Barry style you have a syntax error so
that's why you need to create a an extra
call I can with the token okay this
proposal has an extensive documentation
for further enhancements after this
[Music]
baseline baseline proposal you should
check that out that is there there are
some links on the end of this
presentation so as a counterpart we have
the F sharp proposal which only tries to
other is the ambiguity of a weight step
of a weight by using an unweighted step
so it seems to be simpler than than
smart pipelines proposed but still we
have to override the the arrow function
with parentheses because the F sharp
pipeline proposal doesn't try to address
this one maybe because we still like
maybe if we have the partial application
lending JavaScript the partial
application can replace this this line
with of their error function so just to
summarize the everything about pipeline
operator so it's a nice addition for
create a functional composition in a
streamlined way the minimal purpose has
two caveats the smart pipeline tries to
solve this by ID and talkin and the F
sharp adds just the weight step okay my
point is I really really really like
pipeline operator and I really want to
have this shift as soon as possible so I
would advocate for have the the I think
that the F sharp proposed is just great
like it's just writes off like a small
problem and then we can we could put
possible possibly having this ship to
JavaScript and then afterwards the the
committee could decide that whether
introduce a token as one way of so these
issues are these caveats as the the
smart pipeline tries to to others or I
don't know keep a series nevertheless
bubble seven and adultery has shipped
this my it smart pipeline proposal so I
invite you to try that out not important
so far like because this is this is not
the syntax is not final but please and
try that out okay
before going to the last proposal of
this presentation one to me I want to
make sure some performance tips have you
ever heard about any of these JavaScript
performance tips do you ever wonder why
this is important for the performance of
your application to understand this in
this practice and how they are important
the next propose and how the next
proposal tries to help to mitigate that
we need to check first how the GS engine
is generally generally works so so
hopefully explain how the GS engines
worked I will show this illustration
that I borrowed from excellent article
from address money about startup
reference in JavaScript so whenever the
browser finds a script tag they download
the text content of it and then after it
parses the JavaScript and then generally
the result of this JavaScript is
something called abstract syntax tree or
ast which is a tree representation of
your code
so then afterwards the browser used is
to generate the vertical to do the first
virtual version of the other brainy
JavaScript so this last parts more
regarding the the runtime optimizations
that happens in JavaScript when Dan and
makes the JavaScript executes faster but
this is not targeted for presentation
just to summarize putting short
JavaScript likes I could be described as
generally as startup phase or loading
phase that's the the dull old Parson
compilation runtime phase which is the
the proper execution of the optimization
the optimization bailing out and the
teardown phase which is the garbage
collection but here I want to focus more
on the parsing phase why think about the
code and startup phase in JavaScript we
can see that it's crucial crucial for
the perceived profession or perform
of an application so to make an
application I start faster we end up
doing those kinds of things that we just
spoke in the beginning of this section
but one thing doesn't change the parts
in time parson parson in the initial
compilation of JavaScript could take up
to 30% of the the main tried time and 1
megabyte of uncompressed JavaScript can
easily take a whole second to be parsad
in an average mobile phone normal depth
the browser needs to parse the whole
file before compiling and these are the
motivation for the last propose of this
talk binary is T so the parent in a
binary SC proposal proposes a new over
the wire format for JavaScript which is
based on the binary representation of a
simplified custom ast so this could
potentially decrease the the start of
large J application and the browser that
doesn't support it just can load the
Nommo javascript file so this is how
this may work first we we need to write
or or beautiful delightful piece of
JavaScript so then you can compile it
using your favorite favorite flavor of a
bundle or transpire which provides such
feature and then the processor will give
not only the min J's file but a bean JS
file and and this bin J's file it's a
pre first ast representation of your
javascript file so the browser that
supports it can can have the the parsing
phase the duskily decrease in time since
the majority of this test is doing in a
butte I'm right so the champions of this
proposal create a PLC over spider I spot
a marquee and user government buys on
the it
internal ast and try to compile some
javascript in binary ST and measured
their performance and using the the
Facebook static newsfeed as a benchmark
the POC had the following outcomes
the result of this beauty of the POC was
the following the the size of the binary
st was slightly smaller than the
javascript file and the parsing of
creating the that job is clearly was
between work between 500 800
milliseconds but the time for create ast
was twice as fast as before so this POC
showed the show showed some evidence
that cheap plain binary AST was a good
performance wing that creates some a
second level of X extra notations on the
binary ST file could has enable some
that that code elimination without
relying in the butt and the bundle
bundle plugins like tree shaking and it
it can improve to the point that it this
this annotation improved to the point
that we can enable a streaming
compilation if the performance of this
hypothetical stream compilation has was
closer to the current webassembly stream
completion we can reach to the point
that the compilation time for for the
enhancement EST by name EST could be
faster than a long time amazing right
so to finalize these are links for
further reading and these are my contact
if want to get in touch and Mahalo
you